la foule devant le château de buc pour
le festival de bande dessinée
plus de 8000 passionné pour rencontrer
notamment marc burg présent chaque année
pour dédicacer les réactions des gens
parce que nous on travaille à chez nous
tout seul c'est un travail très
solitaire ce comme un écrivain par
exemple et donc il ya moyen de d'avoir
des retours avec le public sur sur les
réseaux sociaux les choses comme ça même
si ça fait très peu de temps que j'ai dû
me suis décidé à mettre sur les réseaux
sociaux
mais bon c'est toujours plus sympa de
voir les gens en vrai c'est ici dans son
atelier à rambouillet que marc bourgne
créer ce jour là il travaille les
planches d'un nouvel album
[Musique]
c'est un one shot ce qu'on appelle un
one shot c'est à dire une histoire
complète en un album que
que je dessine sur un scénario d'olivier
berlion et de marque au meyer est en
fait la collection l'art du crime c'est
une série de one shot d'histoires
complètes qui sont toutes sur le thème
de l'art et du crime
donc je repasse le crayonné à l'encore
alors j'ai des différences kg de
différentes tailles
avant j'utilisais des plumes mais
j'arrive pas à trouver de bonnes plumes
dont j'étais sdd mon stylo et puis une
plus belle un pinceau et de l'encré de
chine rambolitains depuis toujours marc
bonnet dessinateur et scénariste de
bande dessinée depuis 27 ans une
carrière débutée à 23 ans qui a vu
naître une cinquantaine d'albums
l'autodidacte je suis autodidacte j'ai
fait des études d'histoire en fait donc
j'ai une maîtrise d'histoire à la
sorbonne mais j'ai fait des études
d'histoire pour avoir un métier le temps
de savoir prof d'histoire-géo le temps
de réussir à percer dans la bd sauf que
sauf que j'étais enseignant un trimestre
seulement puisque le premier projet que
j'ai envoyée aux éditeurs a été pris
chez dargaud donc c'était ma première
série le premier album c'est celui ci la
grande-terre dessinée écrite en quatre
mois
mais la bd est une vocation découverte à
10 ans le premier album que j'ai vu
c'était le crabe aux pinces d'or
donc c'est pas très original mais bon
c'était la première bd qui était un vrai
choc c'était
évidemment un album de tintin donc j'ai
été très fans d'hergé je le suis
toujours d'ailleurs
parmi ses inspirations tintin donc mais
aussi alix de jacques martin blueberry
dessiné par jean giraud ou encore le
michel vaillant de jean graton un héros
qu'il dessine aujourd'hui avec benjamin
bénéteau 2 puis 6 tomes